like a certain group of Galaxy Guardians
we know these picks are the perfect
bunch to get you through your weekend
along with the Guardians turning in
another volume we're bringing you a
series that got Joe Pesci out of acting
retirement another wild dystopian Sci-Fi
show to keep your mind spinning a mini
series from the world of Bridgerton and
the return of one of Star Wars most
unique properties Rotten Tomatoes
doesn't mean to be peshy I mean pushy
but come on let's get going already it's
what to watch I want you all to know
that I'm grateful to fight beside my
friends
incinerate them
firing up that Zoom playlist one last
time in theaters is Guardians of the
Galaxy Vol 3. after a slew of positive
reviews coming out of its Premiere last
week volume 3's opening Tomato Meter
score is singing to the tune of
certified fresh at 80 percent at nearly
190 reviews with many critics calling it
a worthy and emotional send-off we'll
have to wait just a little longer but
it's looking good to be certified fresh
which would add yet another certified
fresh Trilogy to the MCU record and
probably the biggest reason to catch
this one is that according to writer
director James Gunn it will conclude the
story of this iteration of the Guardians
Zoe Saldana and Dave Bautista have
stated this will be their last times
playing Gamora and Drax respectively
volume 3 not only finds the gang on a
mission to protect rocket but will also
feature flashbacks to tell his backstory
a story that has been reported not to
hold back on its maturity and emotion I
think we've hinted enough that you
should be prepared to get wrecked and
finally we can confirm there are two
post credit scenes at the end so be sure
to stick around wanted to spend a little
time with my grandsons what it's all
about you're not supposed to smoke here
what are you a forest ranger premiering
on peacock this week is the comedy
series bump kiss now there's a whole
bunch of reasons to spend some time with
this one starting with the fact that it
stars and was co-created by Pete
Davidson and it's a fictionalized
version of his real life drawing
comparisons to Larry David's Curb Your
Enthusiasm not a bad comparison I must
say but we're just getting started
because along with the amazing Edie
Falco playing his mother Davidson was
able to pull the Joe Pesci out of acting
retirement this marks his first role
since 2019 and his first TV role since
1985. yes gen Z the 80s were real and
much like the aforementioned curb upkis
will also be coming in hot with a ton of
guest appearances from people like
Charlie Day Sebastian Stan Method Man
and Al Gore just to name a few in other
words just go on and watch it already
what if what we see is not what's out
there
down a mechanical there's always someone
who has a theory about the sign up I
need to find out the truth another new
series coming at you this week is the
Apple TV Plus drama Silo first off this
one features a talented cast that
includes Rashida Jones David oyelowo and
Rebecca Ferguson not a weak Link in that
group am I right and while a cool title
like Silo could mean anything this one
is quite literal as the show takes place
in a toxic dystopian future where a
community exists deep underground in a
giant Silo plus it's based on The Silo
series of novels by Hugh Howie so you
know there's some depth there get it
depth deep underground okay anyway it
looks like early reviews have critics
feeling pretty good about this one like
Empire Magazine's John Nugent who said
there's a thrilling riddle to unfurl
here rich with real world implications
and analogies ooh tell us more John
where is The King The King cannot see
you now Charlotte now require privacy
she's his wife she should know there is
nothing to know
taking the throne as the next spot on
this list is a Netflix limited series
Queen Charlotte a Bridgerton story this
is a prequel spin-off of the popular
series Bridgerton which has two
certified fresh Seasons By the way this
one focuses on the rise of young Queen
Charlotte with goldarushul reprising the
role from Bridgerton along with a
handful of other recognizable and fresh
faces to round out the cast Queen
Charlotte was created and written by
Shonda Rhimes who certainly knows a
thing or two about creating successful
Series in shondo We Trust of course you
could listen to the critics too who have
this one coming in at certified fresh in
the very high 90s on the Tomato Meter
and fear not Bridgerton fans because the
critics consensus calls it a spin-off
that arguably perfects the primary
series formula and yes Julie Andrews is
the narrator for this one too don't
afraid
[Music]
the force be with you
it's showtime
finally seeing its way back onto our
screens is the second season of Star
Wars Visions before we look ahead let's
look back at the very certified fresh
first season of the show which consisted
of nine short films produced by various
Japanese animation Studios gotta love it
creators were allowed to re-envision the
ideas of Star Wars as they saw fit while
also getting some guidance from
lucasfilm's executive team along the way
such a cool way to approach things and
to take it up a notch or should I say to
take a global season 2 will feature
animation shorts from Studios all around
the world this time including Spain
South Korea Ireland South Africa and
even the good old U.S of a whatever it's
Star Wars I'm in
all right that's our list this week if
you don't want to watch Joe Pesci's new
show we don't want to be there when you
tell them and be sure to let us and your
fellow viewers know in the comments what
you did watch whether it was on this
list or not remember to visit
rottentomatoes.com for the latest
updates on scores and reviews for
everything mentioned as well as the
movie and TV World At Large and don't
forget to stop by the new rt25 page
where we're celebrating 25 years of Ron
Tomatoes it's a party over there that's
all for today fresh family until next
week stay fresh
foreign